next up my shopping guide to getting the
finest fish
well I buy my fish only want the
freshest and the best and if anyone
knows how to get the best is Roger Ken
Bob he's been buying and selling fish at
the world-famous Billingsgate market in
London for over 50 years I love it I
think it's the greatest food of all time
I so literally every variety there is I
could feed you a different fish 365 days
a year this guy really knows how to
sniff out the good from the bad
Oh fish smell different the longer it's
around the more fishy it will smell when
it's lovely and fresh it doesn't smell
whenever you're going to buy fish don't
be fine get your nose right into it then
go like get it into it smelly smells
delightful
it smells like I called salmony and it's
lovely
barramundi so lovely fish the way to
tell good fishes look at it closely it's
shining it still got the blue money its
eyes are bright as yours look in the
girl love Ian red put it in a bag for
the gentleman please people should
always be asking about their fish what
kind of fish is it where's it come from
and I salmon 19 bout it's a bargain at
20 pound Rogers right stand ones
brilliant value and a great all-rounder
really healthy and super delicious
here's a quick look at the different
cuts and how to use them
whole salmon always impresses it's
fantastic stuffed and steamed either in
a fish kettle or in the oven wrapped in
foil steaks are great value and
brilliant baked a side of salmon is
perfect for poaching home curing or
baking and pastry the Phil it is so
versatile easy faster cook and great for
pan frying smoked salmon delicious
cooked or raw I love it with scrambled
eggs broadly there's white fish and this
oily fish they come under two different
sections here we have white fish it's
lovely it's cold it's the best car in
the world it comes to a place called
Peter head it's nice and white the
whites are the better one of the most
all official fine mate well there it is
lovely color with most fish the fresher
they are the harder they are if you're
not well and you're ill have a Macbook
sprats otherwise known as top axe here
we have flatfish and these are known as
place as you can see they've got spots
the redder they are the fresher they are
it really is a lovely fish story King
George couldn't have better for fish
fresh enough for royalty follow your
fish mongers advice and you'll never
ever have another dodgy Dover sole again
poaching the salmon in the miso stir
gives it really nice sort of sweet white
bait are an oily fish there are healthy
delicious and cooking minutes